a new report from deadline reveals the
Harry Potter television reboot is
inching ever closer to becoming a
reality we also get our first look at
four different names who could
potentially lead the project perhaps
even more of Interest though is that Max
seems very open to the idea of doing
more than one Potter show so those who
are hoping for spin-offs rather than a
retelling of the original story may not
need to give up hope just yet last April
Max and WB made the initial announcement
of a brand new TV series that would
reboot the Harry Potter story and bring
it to a new generation Max Executives
and author JK Rowling made it a point to
talk about how this faithful adaptation
would allow for a degree of depth and
detail only possible with long form
television now the latest update from
deadline indicates that while we are
still early the project is ramping up
multiple writers have already met with
Max and WB Executives to make pitches on
how they would go about retelling the
Potter Story the first of those names is
British writer Martha hiler mostly known
for her work as executive producer on
Netflix's hit show the last Kingdom
she's also written 10 episodes for the
British crime drama Vera up next we have
Kathleen Jordan creator of the teenage
Bounty Hunter series on Netflix she also
has writing credits for 10 episodes of
the lifetime series American princess
there's also British writer Tom Moran
creator of Amazon's the devil's hour
Moran also wrote an episode for Wild
Bill a crime comedy TV series starring
Rob low and two episodes for the 2019
sci-fi series The feed and then we have
Michael Lesley writer for The Hunger
Games the ballot of song birds and
snakes you may also remember hearing
Leslie's name associated with peacock's
reboot of Battlestar Galactica however
he ended up leaving the project instead
Leslie chose to work on Hulu's
adaptation of Margaret Atwood's mad atom
Trilogy according to deadline these four
were commissioned to make pitches for a
series reflecting their take on the IP
this initial meeting took place in La
between the writers as well as
Executives from Max and WB they'll then
pick their finalist and those writers
will move to a second second round in
the UK ultimately rolling would need to
sign off on anyone tapped to lead the
project so this UK meeting would be an
important step before a final decision
is made now other than the last Kingdom
I can't say I'm terribly familiar with
any of these shows or these writers but
what about you guys do you have an early
favorite here leave a comment and let me
know which one would be your top pick
now there are two other huge takeaways
on this report from deadline first they
indicate There's an opportunity for more
than one of these writers to be involved
so while it may seem like these four are
vying for one spot that may not
ultimately be the case TV shows of this
magnitude have many writers and
producers working on the project in
various stages so this isn't really a
huge surprise what is a surprise though
is that deadline also mentions Max is
open to the possibility of developing
more than one idea based on Harry Potter
and that my friends is the big one as
someone who follows this Phantom pretty
closely I would say the reaction to the
reboot has been a bit of a mixed bag
there are some who flat out don't want
to see it think it's too soon and
believe that nothing can replace the
original films then you have those who
are looking forward to it and seeing the
opportunity to tell a more faithful
version of the original book series
opposed to what the movies were able to
do but one thing that the vast majority
of fans are in agreement on is how we
would all love to see more stories from
The Wizarding World stories about maybe
the founders of Hogwarts the creation of
the school which we surprisingly know
very little about maybe more backstory
on Harry's parents and the Marauders
while they were in school or what about
Tom Riddle's Youth and his rise to power
as Voldemort for me personally I could
get on board with any of these
directions I think my favorite idea
though would be something that's
completely original with unknown
characters I mean couldn't you see like
an adventure series about a traveling
group of Curse Breakers or maybe a
mystery series that follows around a
couple of aurors who are solving complex
Wizarding World crimes now while this is
certainly exciting and it's fun to
speculate and theorize the bad news here
is that we are still very much a long
way from any of this happening deadlines
report does not speculate on when that
second meeting is set to take place and
their sources do indicate the process is
very much in the early stages that being
said these are all key steps before the
project can move into pre-production
which would really be a fun time to
follow his fans that's when we'll start
to get info in the cast and crew and
likely more details about the actual
plan for the show which Max has touted
as being a decade long series at this
point it's not clear on how they plan on
splitting up the books to work across a
10-year span I originally assumed this
time frame would mean we'll get some of
the larger books spread out over
multiple Seasons but several of you
pointed out in my last video about the
TV show that this isn't necessarily the
case they could have a year or two where
we actually don't get a new season at
all this could be especially helpful as
they get toward the end of the series
it's going to give them more time to
plan and film maybe some of those large
scale battle scenes not to mention all
the different sets that are going to be
required for all that travel that's
happening in Deathly Hallows and then
let's say they do actually decide to
proceed with multiple Wizarding World
projects how would they handle the
release schedule for both shows
personally I believe they'll want to get
the reboot off the ground and moving in
the right direction first before working
on any other spin-offs I think that is
going to be the priority Warner Brothers
Discovery president and CEO David zaslav
has really made it known that he wants
the company to double down and focus on
their IP their big icon ionic characters
like of course Harry Potter characters
that are known across the world and my
guess is that he would want to see the
Potter name out there before any other
spin-off series can move forward but who
knows maybe if the pitch is strong
enough perhaps the executives could be
persuaded to give the go aead and now on
both of them at the same time this
desire for more stories in The Wizarding
World is part of the reason that
Hogwarts Legacy was 2023 is best-selling
video game and speaking of the hit title
from Avalanche software there was even a
rumor at one point about a possible
Hogwarts Legacy TV show which I would
certainly love to see that just went
dead quiet though we never heard
anything else about it and on that one I
can think of plenty of ideas maybe they
could even do some sort of AA crime
mystery show during that era kind of
like what I did recently investigating
11 mysterious deaths in Hogwarts Legacy
yeah if you guys didn't hear about this
Legacy actually has 11 NPCs who all died
in mysterious ways notes are left behind
to help you piece together the puzzle
and figure out how they died and I got
to say some of these are pretty out
there if you're curious guys you'll
definitely want to check that video out
next big thank you to all of our channel
members who help make these videos
possible if you're not yet subscribed to
the channel make sure to do so and stay
up to dat on all the latest news
theories and discussion in The Wizarding
World of Harry Potter as always guys
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon